انا انا شخص موسيقي ولا اتكلم في السياسه
بشكل كبير لكنه بعض ال- ال- قد تكون
واظن هذا ظن يعني شخصي وتحليلي شخصي ان
بعض المقالات قد يكون لها توجهات مختلفه
همم وتشكيك في قرارات المنصه وساعدهم في
هذا الموضوع الاخطاء اللي صارت في قياده
المنصه في البدايه فلذلك قد بعض المنصات
تكون او بعض المحطات او الشركات الاخباريه
غير راضيه بشكل جدا كبير عن هذا الاستحواذ
لانه يؤثر عليهم بشكل سلبي وقد يكون فيه
ترامب هذه لها دور كل جدا كبير لكن لازم
نطرق لموضوع ليه التركيز حاليا فقط على
تويتر وان فصل نصف الموظفين ولا في احد
تكلم عن فيسبوك همم اوبر وغيرها من
الشركات اللي استغنت عن عدد معين للموظفين
مرر خبر في اسمك ترى مرور الكرام 11 11
تتكلم انا لا ادافع عن تويتر لكنه القارئ
اللي ينظر الاخبار يجد ان تويتر متواجد
بشكل فعلي خلال الايام الحاليه ممكن بسبب
يعني ان حاليا الاخبار التي تكتبها عن
تويتر تجيب تفاعل للمنصات هذه وتجيب قراء
اكثر منصات هذه يكون هذا الاسباب ترى